Nó này 1 một táng bẩy năm 2019, tàn quốc chính thức bận hành mua hình chính quyền địa phương 2 cấp.
Theo đó, cả nước có 3 mưu tình, thành phố và 3 gình và trăm 2 mưu đơn vị hành chính cấp 3,
một chính thị hành chính mới của đất nước. Đây là thời điểm liệt sự, đang giống một dạng phát triển mới của sự nghiệp hoàn thiện mộ máy hành chính nhà nước,
khoàn thiện thị trế và tổ chức của hệ thống chính trị đồng bộ.
Tinh gọi hiệu lực hiệu quả, thương tối hoàn thiện một nền hành chính quả chỉ hiện đại, kính thạo,
vần dân, sát dân, biến nhân dân phục phụ để mọi lợi thục biến nhân dân.
Bình tổ chức lại để giới hành chính, và thành mua hình chính quyền địa phương mới lại yêu cầu hệ quan và tất yêu của sự nghiệp phát triển đất nước trong mối cạnh bản cầu quá.
Chỉnh đổi số và cuộc cách mạng công nghiệp lần thứ tư.
Như thông địa của tổ bii thư tổ lâm chúng ta đang đứng trước bận hội lớn.
Mỗi tổ chức, mối cộng đồng, mối cà nhân đều là một mắt sĩ quan trọng trong vụ quay cải cách mạnh mẽ này.
Mối người dân Việt Nam trong nước hay ở nước ngoài, đều có phải trọng và chết hiện công dân trong việc đưa đất nước đi lên,
vừa qua khòa khăn, phát hình luận lực, chân thủ ngoại lực làm chủ tương lai của chính mình.
Hãy để mối ngày làm việc là một ngày kiến thạo.
Hãy để mối người là một chiến sĩ trên mặt trận đổi mối.
Hãy để tinh thần tiến công cách mạng mạnh mẽ, quyết liệt và sáng thạo, thâm đấm vùng dân tộc trong tường hành động,
tương quyết sách và tương bước phát triển đi lên.
Đối hôm nay, chúng ta tiếp tục trung tay, đồng lòng, đàn kết, nhất chi thực hiện thành công môi hình chính quyền địa phương 2 cấp,
bảo đảm hệ thống tổ chức bệnh hành trường trụ.
Híu lực, hiệu quả, bảo vệ quyết lời chính đáng của người dân,
trong lâu ác sĩnh sã hội và mở giống cơ hội phát triển cho mọi tân lớp nhân dân.